is a self-made Indian billionaire we've
seen him buy up asset after asset across
the country ports airports power plants
whenever he speaks about his group he
always says that his conglomerates goals
are aligned to India's goals
in the India growth story that gives the
adani group going
as recently as just a few months ago he
was the second richest person in the
world
to his critics however he's a more
complicated figure
political observers think adani is very
close to prime minister Narendra Modi
this is one of the Hot Topics when
Narendra Modi came to power
on the morning of January 24th about a
couple hours after sunrise in Mumbai
journalists across the country were
greeted with a large 100-page document
from Hindenburg research in which it
accused this Empire of essentially stock
manipulation and accounting fraud there
was an instant Market reaction
in adani companies we're looking at
losses of north of 130 billion dollars
the last thing Moody wants is to be
involved in any of this Mark there is no
doubt that the government of India needs
Empire Builders like adani but
underlying all of that there was a
sentiment that if adani fails what
happens to India's own ambitions
[Music]
if you're living or visiting in this
country you really cannot be independent
of an adani asset coal mined from adani
coal mines is transported through adani
ran Forts and railroads into power
plants that adani owns the electricity
generated from these power plants then
runs through adani-owned grids into
homes built with adani cement
he keeps very very low profile we have
not seen him splashing money buying
luxurious cars or buying yacht or
holidaying in luxurious destination
the relationship between adani and Modi
go back decades even before Modi was
prime minister
both of them hail from the same state of
Gujarat renowned for sending out
entrepreneurs around the world adani has
grown so big so fast
adani is aligning the business goals of
the adani conglomerate with the girls of
Prime Minister Modi if you want to grow
a country you need to build your
airports you need to build your
infrastructure such as electricity grids
and power plants it's very natural that
he will lean towards a big businessman
big conglomerates big business groups to
develop such kind of stuff
if Modi has come to the world stage as a
political leader who understands the
needs of business adani has been a big
contributor to building this image
there's another level of questioning
about whether adani is actually funding
Prime Minister Modi
for instance Prime Minister Modi when he
was campaigning for his first term in
office he very publicly flew in an adani
plane
the party claims that they paid the
adani group rent for use of this plane
India's political funding was always
opaque but since Modi has come to power
there's an added level of opaque
the adani group has repeatedly denied
Financial improprieties or receiving
favors from the government
research is a firm Incorporated in New
York City
[Music]
it was registered by Nathan Anderson who
is what we would call a short seller he
exposes discrepancies in accounting with
the intention of course of driving down
stock prices it was very strongly worded
delegation because it said its biggest
Con in India's corporate history it
wiped off more than 100 billion dollars
itself one report and a few trading
sessions has taken madani from the top
list of world's richest men
there were many allegations in the
Hindenburg report against adani the main
allegation was that people close to
gather madani used offshore shell
companies to pump up the prices of stock
in adani's listed firms he then
according to these allegations used
these pumped up share prices as
collateral to borrow more money from
Banks
Bloomberg has investigated some of the
funds these are all Mauritius entities a
country known as attacks Haven that have
little or no information on who are The
Beneficial owners of these funds
essentially where the money Trail leads
to
[Music]
has published a lengthy rebuttal to
allegations of fraud by a short seller
Hindenburg research the report is a
malicious combination of selective
misinformation stale baseless and
discredited allegations the fundamentals
of our company are very strong our
balance it is healthy and assets robust
when the Hindenburg report came out
there were several people in India
nationalists of course being among the
Forefront of these who said that this
was just an attempt to malign the image
of India
conglomerate saying that any attack
towards adani group is attacked towards
India's goals
they were trying to reiterate to us they
never defaulted any payments in their
history
and they always maintained about a
conservative cash management tactics
so what does Hindenburg research
allegation is done to adani aggressive
expansion has been slowed down the capex
has been slowed down you will not see
Gautam madani as a busiest deal maker in
2023 unlike in 2022 the they are
continuing with this process of
pre-paying and repaying a whole lot of
debt that seems to be very big part of
how they're trying to portray themselves
as this very good corporate citizen as
the opposite basically of what
Hindenburg had alleged so there's good
debt and there's bad debt of course you
have to have debt but what is the level
of debt you can keep that is a key
question the critical lesson learned in
this entire episode is how robust is
your regulatory framework how robust is
your Judiciary framework and how good is
Indian landscape to do business as India
looks to tap Western Capital more
frequently it will necessarily have to
adapt to Western ways of doing business
India will have to open up its
accounting books to Western eyes to
answer to the question whether adani
group is too big to fail it's a trickier
one
it can survive the you know Hindenburg
research allegations because it is built
on strong fundamentals and it never
defaulted
next year Modi of course has
re-elections this is something that Modi
will pull no stops to get at his party
wants the third term in office and once
it gets that third term in office Modi
then needs to cement his legacy and for
that he needs billionaires like Gotham
adani
foreign
[Music]